uh you said non-traditional relationship
of sorts yeah well
that's that is that like the like the
quote unquote non-traditional
relationship of sorts that's like
explain that that's like the elevator
pitch i'm in a one-way open relationship
so that means like i can have sex with
other girls wow but i'm emotionally
exclusive to my girlfriend uh she only
has sex with me
okay and you have sex with
everybody
not everybody i'm slowed down i'm not as
fun as i used to be
uh-huh and how old are you buddy
i'm 32. 32. and how you been with your
girl
two years now two years and just
walk me through that initial
conversation where it's like baby i love
you
but
and then you
da da da da fill in the blanks please
when i was younger i used to get into a
lot of situations where i would commit
to relationships but then like four or
five months in i'd be like i really want
to [ __ ] around and i had to make a
choice either lie and cheat on my
girlfriend which is obviously never
pleasant or suppress that desire and
then i built resentment towards my
girlfriend so it was a lose-lose either
way so as i got older i realized that
while i like the emotional intimacy of
having a girlfriend i don't like the
being limited when it comes to my sexual
i don't know let's just say escapades so
then i decide that the only way i'm
gonna get a relationship is if i have
the option of having sex with other
girls i don't use that option nearly as
much as like you would think i do uh but
yeah i like having that option does she
have the option
no that's why it's a one-way open
relationship but because she chose that
or because you chose that well of course
he would well i mean no because some
girls are like you're all i need and
that's fine you can do your thing but
like you're all i need i just want to
know if it was her
oh yeah yeah she's perfectly happy with
it but it but you proposed the idea uh
we both proposed it basically i kind of
respect that actually to be honest
because i think all guys cheat
so i really do
okay i'm not all guys not all guys okay
one one percent doesn't cheat okay
so whatever i don't think it's that i
don't think it's that low but i also
think it's not but go on guys two times
but i actually respect that you did that
because i was just talking to
actually to my makeup artist about that
and i'm like my next relationship might
be that like what you're doing so you'd
like you're gonna do it the other way
around where you're the one that has the
option no no no no no no i would let him
like i would be like look we're
together maybe i will like do like the
military you know like don't ask don't
tell or maybe he just has to be honest
with me but i'm also jealous but when i
get into relationships i don't do boy
girl scenes so it's just me and the guy
do you know what i mean
so i do actually respect your
relationship i think that's cool well i
appreciate you appreciating it yeah yeah
yeah amber do you appreciate this or
this is something that is a hard no for
you
uh for me personally yes uh yeah it
would definitely have to be mutual
mutual what uh like that would it open
i'm i'm i think along came polyamory is
the future but um in terms of
me not being able to or not being
allowed to that wouldn't absolutely not
so if you would agree to that for your
man he would have to agree for you to do
this absolutely and i think that that is
a great option for the future i'm like
looking for a life partner that i get to
like we're like hey we're in this we do
this we raise a kid we have a we do
everything together
and we communicate through it if you
want to go experience something you do
it if i want to do it i do it and then
we come back together and keep doing the
partnership but just you getting to
because it's all connected to your
confidence i think that being validated
like sure maybe it's just sexual but i
think it also relates to um how you feel
about yourself and we get validated by
other people so i think if both people
get validated by other people then they
come back to your partner stronger and
more confident and it can be very
mutually beneficial but one side
the problem is a lot of dudes have that
issue they want to be the only ones
penetrating you when they're dating you
do you know what i mean of course and if
they're providing for you financially
then that's another factor
some guys are not if i'm providing for
you you can't be using your free will to
go be okay well 100 if i'm paying all
your bills
hello
but if you pay all your girls bills no
she does her own thing yeah she's pretty
financially successful okay
what does she do uh she works in
marketing
all right
okay so only got so many questions for
alex we're gonna get there so stay tuned
by the way i would like to get her only
yeah by the way um so if you like that
clip click right here to watch another
or if you want to watch the entire sauce
cast click right here
[Music]